okay next
game give me
i don't know some guy from france
the caracon okay
i play the advance
the immediate c5 interesting
but at least um
he's giving me the two bishops right
away
yeah an interesting position black
pretty
pretty early on conceded the two bishops
in order to um
to get in a quick c5
um okay
maybe knight defense offered
well i don't take a draw why should i
okay we're going directly into an
interesting end game
of course i've got two bishops but this
is um
maybe not so important
at least not for the moment he's got two
fine minor pieces
as well
and d4 is of course a potential weakness
what i'd like to do is um
i think um exchanging rooks
would be a good idea and i'm also
somewhat behind in development i need to
catch up a bit there
i try to play um
king d2 and um bishop e2
quickly you know black is certainly okay
here
yeah this was expected
to get a square there
okay just bishop e2 now
okay how to proceed further
is it an idea to to get a look to c5
maybe
let's try this of course he can
maybe go well night before doesn't make
much sense i think
he doesn't have any any great square to
go to
oh maybe interesting maybe knight b4
a3 knight a1 knight a2
was a weird idea maybe interesting
okay he just retweeted
the question now is should i exchange
rooks now
yeah i think this should be okay
my king is also very close to the queen
side
so i might
simply have the chance to to open it up
there
yes of course so a form
now he has to take
i think he has to take whatever else
otherwise i just take b5
or a6 of course before a6 is just
hanging
or maybe is some trick
no not sure um
i think he just needs to take i'm not
sure what he's
what he's thinking about maybe he's
realizing that he's got a bad position
now but
still it's the only move okay yeah this
was an idea
because of knight a5
but still um i have a hard time
believing it
okay i need to take that's not
not much else okay let's say
if i transpose now with bishop d3
and two to the end game directly he
takes on b3 with checking e3
then he needs to take needs to exchange
what what is what about this position
we've got the b worth of ca pawn but
i've got my king working there it should
shouldn't this be winning
let's try it maybe this
i had some other options but this is
certainly the most straightforward
okay needs to take now what else
i'm not sure what is calculating
check
okay now um exchange bishops
no he doesn't exchange bishops this is
interesting
i didn't take that into account okay
time warning
check
my dear simply bishop d2
trying to win a pawn there
or for some concession
this was also my idea with the bis with
the bishops exchanged
i think it should should be okay here as
well
okay
g2 now
check oh my god i didn't see
okay just just just a simple blunder
yeah okay this was of course um just
stupid
to get a losing position here's um it
was really
really really bad
but had had a very very clear advantage
check yeah
play on a bit but it's of course
completely lost
check
yeah this was very very unnecessary loss
okay i can resign this
design yeah stupid to blender d4
of course very stupid
yeah maybe this wasn't so great after
all okay this position is good for white
no
no no question but
maybe um
check maybe this wasn't so clear-cut
interesting
computer yet suggests bishop c1
bishop c1
with an equal position they cannot take
because of a5 and the pawn is
going through okay
check
yeah i need to play bishop e3 here and
then the game just
just continues
white still should be somewhat better
also confirmed by the engine
but this isn't i should i should have
more really this is just
just the crab position for black
yeah maybe it's not that easy i'm i'm
just
overestimating this
interesting really yeah
no idea another
simple idea here is um is to just ignore
the queen side and
gain space on the king side black simply
cannot do anything in this position i i
could also
for instance just play a3 here a3 bishop
c3
engine then push the king side f3 g4
h4 h5 f4 g5 and so on
and black can just await proceedings so
to say
so this is um this is just very nice for
white
of course it's um it's terrible that i
just blended the form
yeah this is just stupid completely
overlooked
d4 hanging so i need to play bishop e3
and then it
it just continues
yeah okay let's um forget this one start
a new game